Meagen Eisenberg, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm doing well. Thank you.
Thank you for being here.
So, you're so so busy.
I mean, just the track that you've done
and the things that you're doing now
with TripActions,
a company that I love so much,
as the chief marketing officer.
And previously
the chief marketing officer of MongoDB.
And Vice President at Docusign.
So, really fascinating things.
And what I'd love to talk about
for the next 20 minutes,
is to hear a little bit about your journey
and about the role of the CMO,
and how you've watched different companies
scale their marketing efforts
through time.
So Meagen, maybe you can give me
a little bit of background
about who you are
and why are you so passionate
about marketing?
Yeah. Since business school,
I went to undergrad
was MIS computer science,
but I pivoted to business
during business school
to marketing for tech companies.
And haven't looked back.
I love it.
I definitely have picked up skills
along the way.
Started out in product marketing.
Switched over to really
lead generation, demand generation,
understanding what it takes
to build pipeline
for your sales team.
And then more recently, as a CMO,
learning more on the brand
building corporate communications.
And I think
when you look at companies that scale
and when you come into a company,
there's three things
I'm trying to figure out
that I need to focus on
between hiring the right people,
because to scale you need
the right skill set and marketing
has a lot of functions
that are very different,
whether it's product marketing,
corporate marketing, demand and growth,
web systems, operations, and then
localization for Europe and Asia.
So, people's number one.
Process, making sure
you have the right process
around launches,
partnering with your sales team,
lead flow. And then technology.
We have over 25 different technologies.
And about every company I've entered,
whether it was DocuSign,
MongoDB, or TripActions,
I brought in a lot of MarTech
and complemented that
with a lot of SalesTech and partnering.
And that's where you get
a lot of insights and data.
And you can compete in the market
when you know what's going on.
And technology helps us innovate.
That's why we buy software
that gives us a competitive advantage.
That's why I love working
at tech companies,
because you really can take markets better
when you have information
and you know what's working
and what's not working.
So, talk to me a little bit about
this notion of lead generation.
Why is this such a difficult
and complicated subject?
Because to an average engineer
coming into the world of marketing,
you say,
"Okay. Well, I've built a great product.
I have a landing page.
I can put some ads somewhere.
And yeah, everybody will just flock
to my product.
It should be pretty easy"
But I guess it's not.
Yeah. When it comes to scale,
that's getting to the masses,
and the masses don't always find products
the same way.
Sometimes they read about it.
Sometimes a friend tells them about it.
Sometimes they see it on social media.
Sometimes you email them.
Sometimes they're in at an event
when we used to do events.
And so, you've got to figure out
the persona you're targeting
that's most likely to buy your product
and get in front of them
so they're aware of you
and then they take an action.
And so marketing's job
is to understand who the buyer is,
why they buy you,
and then get in front of them.
They're fishing out in a big ocean.
So, you've got to figure out
where the fish are,
you have to have the right bait,
and then you've got to bring them in
and hand them off to sales to close them.
And is that the same process
when you're a 20 person company
and when you're a 200 person company?
Is it the same sort of pipelines
for trying to get sales?
No, it's not.
It's the same idea that you need
to understand the persona
you're targeting,
but when you're a 20 person company,
that's hand-to-hand combat.
That is who do you know
in your network that can get you
help you get introduced
into the first five, 10, 20 companies
that become customers.
And so, it's very targeted.
Direct relationships.
You usually have someone
in Biz Dev or sales
who's got these relationships
with that target audience,
whether it's IT or finance or HR
whatever
depending on who you're selling to.
And you get in and you solve problems.
And you're still trying to figure out
product market fit in the beginning.
So, it's hard to scale until you know
what is the core reason
people are buying you.
And you don't really know that
when you're a 20 person company.
You might get some bluebirds,
you might get some stuff,
but ultimately,
the product's gonna pivot
and shift around
until you lock on something
that many people want to buy.
And you don't really know that
in the early stage.
But how do you even go
about ... that persona?
Because, fine.
So, I have a few thousand people
that I know have purchased the product.
I know that they're using it.
I might be able to even have analytics
into their actual usage patterns.
But how do you actually
feel comfortable and confident
writing down who are the top promoters
or the champions of this product?
Yeah. I mean, who bought it
is the first one. Who signed the deal.
If you have that many customers,
go and talk to the admin or the manager.
Understand and really ask
in about five to six questions,
you can find out why they bought it.
And keep digging in.
And then ask your sales team.
They're gonna know, right.
Often they know who they want to talk to,
'cause they have a successful pattern
of the messaging,
what it resonates with.
So, talk to your best sales rep,
who do they want to talk to ultimately,
and then talk to your customers.
Why did they buy?
Who's the owner of the product?
What was the pain they felt?
Is it a HR pain?
Is it a finance pain?
Is it a marketing pain?
Depending on why they bought
your software, there's pain there
that you're solving for them,
and that's gonna be
the target audience.
Right.
So, within the companies
that you've got to be in
and from your understanding of the arena,
at what point do the sales
start to impact dramatically
the progression of the product?
So, at what point in the company
do the sales now come in
and they're actually becoming sort of
the product people,
because they are starting to know
the needs of the customers
just as well as the product managers
that initially designed the products?
I mean, I think if you've had
a lot of a bats, a lot of conversations,
a lot of demos, failures and successes,
you start to get very familiar
with the product.
But when you're scaling,
you often bring in new reps
who don't know the industry.
They're just good at selling.
So, it's your job in product marketing
and sales enablement to train them
or to bring in sales engineers
that really deeply understand the industry
and the product to help support them
and answer those questions
that they haven't brought up
to speed on. But part of market and sales
is to get your reps to be productive.
And part of being productive
is really knowing.
So there's sales training,
there's ramping,
there's a knowledge base
you've got to transfer.
And the faster you can do that,
the better you're going to do in sales.
Right. Right.
Okay. That makes a lot of sense.
Now, one of the things
that you touched upon before
was this whole notion of using technology
to leverage better sales
and better understanding
of what's happening.
So, what's happening today in 2020
that maybe wasn't available 15 years ago
- Oh my goodness
in the arena of marketing?
Or even 10 years ago?
- So much
I saw a talk you gave
seven years ago in 2013 on YouTube.
You were talking about
this whole idea of automated marketing,
right,
and understanding your customers.
And I was just thinking like, Wow.
How much has changed
in the past seven years
that you were talking about back then,
and now we're in 2020.
Yeah. I mean they always say
half of marketing spend is effective
you just don't know which half.
Well, since then we have a lot of software
that gives us attribution information.
You've got things like Visible.
You've got things like Full Circle CRM.
You've got tools that allow you
to analyze the workflow.
And on the sale side,
things we didn't have.
We have recordings from chorus.ai
and other vendors in the space
that analyze what's talked about,
how to respond,
you can see what they're talking about,
what the points are,
what the customer brings up.
So I can see how I need
to better train reps,
content they need,
customer stories they may
or may not have.
Your website.
I mean the whole thing.
Most people will go to your website
at some point.
98% of all people go to your website.
But if you don't know who's there
and what they're doing on it,
that's something you didn't know
15 years ago.
But now we know who's on our website.
We know what they're doing.
How long they sit there.
What assets matter.
What helps them convert.
Are they going to the demo?
Are they not?
And we move things around and say,
"Oh, that captured a lot more people."
My job is not only
to get people to the website,
but to capture them
and get them in a active conversation.
Even to schedule a calendar.
We use Chili Piper.
They come, they say they want a demo.
Why wait for someone to call back
to schedule the demo?
It can open up their calendar
and automatically schedule it
between the SDR and the customer
or the prospect.
Right.
So like, take out all
the middleman stuff.
That's what we're doing.
Ads.
You spend a lot of money on paid search.
We now have something like
things like Terminus.
They only show ads to our target accounts.
Why waste money on companies you
don't want to target?
So, these technologies are making us,
giving us a lot more
insightful information,
so we see what's working and what's not
so we can be more efficient
on our budget.
And they help us target
who we want to speak to
that is the right personas,
the right companies
that sales wants to get in front of
and then streamlines the actual demo
getting them in front and them process.
And then are they effective
when they're in front of them.
So there's so many things available today
that we certainly didn't have before.
And that's what makes it fun, too.
I think it's a competitive advantage
to understand the technology landscape
out there and what you can use
to best your competitors,
because you just have more information,
you can move faster than them,
and you can automate stuff.
[crosstalk]
So, is this something that's now new
within companies?
That there are new divisions,
there are new roles for people
who are more on marketing analytics
and leveraging all these technologies
to be able to then guide
the sales representatives
or the chief marketing officer
on what the strategy should be?
Yeah. I mean, there's definitely more
technology focused folks in marketing.
I think when you're a 20 person company,
a lot of times your engineering team
is also doing your website.
But as you mature,
you should bring in
a dedicated web developer,
front end, full stack
so you can quickly learn, pivot, and edit.
And it's a living, breathing site.
It's really your lifeline
for your reps to get a funnel going.
And so, I think as soon
as you can bring in that team,
when you're large enough,
that's gonna be
a much more effective channel
than having to wait for sprints
for the engineering team to make edits
or even outsource it
to a consulting firm to do it.
They're not living and breathing
the day to day.
They're not working the 15 hour days
and the weekends with you,
right.
They're charging you for every hour
and you get so many a day
and it takes a while for them to respond.
In the beginning,
you need to be agile, responsive.
You want people
that own a part of the company
that are working really hard to build it.
You want the
I find it much better
to have them in-house.
No no, definitely.
It makes it just run much faster
and much more flexible.
But are things
going to change dramatically now
in the way of selling B2B
as a result of the new social norms
due to covid?
Because when I imagine sales,
the classic sales,
I imagine somebody coming in with a suit,
taking a few people out to dinner,
maybe a Broadway show,
pitching to them throughout the evening,
and then with drinks signing a deal.
I'm imagining that
it's a little bit different
in software B2B.
But are things changing at all
due to the covid situation?
I mean of course things have changed
in the short term.
I don't think that's a long term.
I mean, there's an Oxford study
for every dollar spent on travel
and going to in-person meetings,
you return $12 in revenue.
Companies are definitely taking a hit.
It's hard to build a relationship
over a virtual conference.
People will get back to meet in person.
C-level execs will travel.
As soon as you're in a deal cycle,
or you're about to lose a customer
to a competitor, I guarantee
you're gonna get on a plane and go fly
especially if it's an enterprise customer.
To me, you're not gonna wait for that.
And if we progress
and we have vaccines come out, I see us
We have customers already traveling.
So, there's industries health care,
retail, manufacturing,
they're all out on the road traveling.
Tech is sitting a little bit back
on the sidelines,
because I think we're tech savvy
and we're all over the technologies
that are out there,
but folks are out there traveling.
In the spring, even maybe winter,
if vaccines start coming out
and the comfort level goes up,
and we have
more and more knowledge every day,
people will get back to traveling.
Maybe it's 50%.
in the next year.
Maybe it's a year and a half to two
where it's back to full,
but I have no doubt people are traveling.
We have consumers out traveling right now, right.
I've already done a trip
to the East Coast and back in June
with my family for a vacation.
Like there are some of us
who have been on the road
that are comfortable.
We understand our risk.
We protect ourselves.
We wear masks.
We wash hands and all of that.
So, that's just growing.
People are not gonna stay
in their houses forever.
Human nature, we're just.
And we have way more advances
than people did 100 years ago
when pandemics and plagues
and everything else hit.
So yeah, it sucks in the short term.
And it's hard to sell.
I've no doubt it's a much harder job,
and if you're a relationship salesperson
that does the dinners and bonds
and breaks bread and all of that,
you've got a lock down
on your value prop
better than ever.
Your ROI, your customer case studies,
proof points.
For sure, value proposition
and messaging matter more than ever.
But we will get back
to the relationship side
because people want to work with people,
buy from people,
and you trust someone
that you've sat down with
and gotten to know much more
than the cues you miss out on over video.
Of course. Of course.
That just leaves me optimistic
after this conversation.
So thank you for that, first of all.
But I also want to talk a little bit about this
You were a protagonist
for a Stanford Business School case study
over MongoDB.
I've been really enjoying
taking some of those classes,
and every time we read the case study,
they're so fascinating
and it's remarkable.
And I can't believe you were a protagonist
in one of those case studies.
So, talk to me a little bit about that
and what that was about.
Yeah.
So, that was MongoDB.
It was when we scaled. We had
When Carlos and I joined,
we had less than 400 people
at the company.
Grew it to about 1,300.
Took it public.
But we had took the marketing team
from 24 people almost up to 80.
Put in a lot of different technologies.
Launched a whole new database
as a service atlas, which is
a totally different business model
than our enterprise product with MongoDB.
And really just bringing in,
we had to bring in the right people,
we had to bring in the right technology,
the right process to scale the company,
become a public company
that's doing quite well in the markets
today even.
And so, just all the learnings of that
and how you build that partnership.
The case study is a lot around the partnership
between marketing and sales,
the communications,
transparency, and results
that we were seeing,
a feedback loop.
And it's ever evolving
because the market's evolving,
the customers you go after are evolving,
and you need to just keep partnering.
I would say it's like a marriage;
you've got to communicate,
you've got to deliver value.
So, that's the main lesson
from that case study is
about communication
and about continuously evolving
within the organization?
Well, it's also about the technology
we implemented, what we needed.
It's about the process
that we put in place,
the methodologies,
how we built out a funnel,
fully evolving funnel, all of that.
I love it. Okay Meagen, I'd love to use
the last just four minutes that we have
to talk a little bit about you
and why you're doing what you're doing.
So, one of the things
that I love hearing about
and gaining so much inspiration from
is where people's passions lie.
So, why marketing?
Why chief marketing officer
of a hypergrowth company, a unicorn?
Why that specific position?
I think marketing
is always changing and really hard.
I think people think
it's events and billboards.
And it's not.
It's actually a mix of art and science.
It's you're dealing with people.
You're supporting
and enabling a sales team.
And they are forever changing
your understanding of customer
that's evolving.
You've got technical people on your team
to do your website, to do operations.
You've got product marketers
who are creating messaging
and positioning.
You've got brand
and corporate communications.
You're dealing with press and media.
You've got to do this worldwide.
So you have European folks
and localization in Asia.
And so I always say
marketing's like the circus
when you go and you put up the plates
and they're spinning.
And you start on one side
and you start spinning it,
and you get all the way around
and then this one starts to fall down
and the idea is to keep it up on the post.
So I always feel like no matter what,
once I get something going,
when I turn this way, all of a sudden
it starts to fall over here.
And so for me, it's just
it's never the same.
It's changing.
You launch new products.
You have new players.
And so I find it exciting,
and I love the creative side of it.
I think brand is fun.
What you have to do
to get people's attention.
It's hard.
There's a lot of noisy stuff going on.
Every channel is noisy.
And then you find a new channel,
you understand it, learn it,
and then a bunch of players
come in and crowd it.
And so, it keeps you up
on what's out there,
what's the technology.
I always think about how I buy,
what gets my attention,
and then how do I apply that
to my business.
And so, I love it.
I think it's very hard,
but it's stimulating.
So, what's like one or two things
that you do to remain updated?
Because you keep talking
about this idea of evolution
and being able to be on top of the game
and being at the forefront.
How do you personally do that?
Because today there's so many startups
in this domain.
So many different advances.
Yeah. I mean, I've advised
a lot of companies.
So, over 25 companies.
That's one way I keep up
on what's going on
'cause they have limited budgets
and their growth hacking
and I get a lot of ideas
and see a lot of things that you could do
without a lot of money.
Two, I have a pretty good network
with other heads of marketing,
VPs of marketing, and CMOs.
So, I exchange ideas with them
all the time.
There's a lot of office hours
and networking going on there.
And then,
I'm constantly following consumer brands.
I mean, how did that person
get my attention.
Whether it's in retail,
whether it's in activities,
things for my kids.
I have three daughters,
so they're active on TikTok
and YouTube and all those things
I don't want them to be on that they love.
And so, they're always giving me ideas.
And so it's a mix of things
that you see and hear.
And then I have a team, right?
I have a team of almost 30 people
that are always coming up with new ideas
that have different experiences.
And I'm listening and learning
and then testing.
Meagen, thank you so much
for being so generous with your time.
I really really appreciate it.
Right before we leave,
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself,
and why those three specific words.
Yeah. I mean, one executive mom.
So I'm working,
but I have three children
which I already talked about.
So I think that's pretty obvious.
I love being in tech
and I love actually working.
And the third word would be hardworking.
I've always got something going on.
I like to be out there doing stuff
and learning and busy.
I think that advising 25 companies
and doing all the things
that you've done along your career,
I think it shows.
Meagen, thank you very very much.
Thank you for all the incredible work
you're doing and for the inspiration
And best of luck.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Take care.